no but I'm hoping everything works the
way it's supposed to this time okay all
right Wade I don't find a wage
I was playing Mitchell Exodus it was
leaving game pass I gotta get my digs in
pause
she's the road I got to finish she's the
rage my bugging out
oh I cannot wait to do this for Lacasse
tomorrow man
yeah I sent out some messages yesterday
we're waiting on some replies but we'll
definitely have a full house I'm not I'm
looking at having no more than four
people in it duh
cool
was good regular Oh what the hell
what okay continue all right we're on
the real run all right cool
can you guys hear King fine in the
hamlet of style
let me check everything should be fine
everything looks fine in the audio how
come I can't invite you to the game he
sounds muffled I'm honest I'm streaming
you got to either take upstairs but she
can't be making all those noise stop
don't do that again
she's on that [ __ ] don't go over to
leave her alone yeah I'm having fish
take it up no no you know what this is
I'm streaming no noise
okay I'm sending you the invite came
okay I don't know why I can't invite you
I was about to bring hard outside
thunder and lightning I told you I'm
streaming keep it down all the people in
the chat man if you guys don't mind
share this on Twitter let all the the
Lord let all the members in the realm
know that uh we we we in here
did you unable to connect to a service
disabled that the Keating let me get on
Twitter right now so I can let the
people know yeah I was the big why can't
I be the normal person and why do I have
to be the big nose I just feel like that
no you're younger that's it I'm younger
okay so we're you is that your daughter
yes sir yes sir that you always use that
card well sitting yeah I mean don't you
love being young you can watch all my
mistakes just don't do I sound huh oh
yeah alright how's that sound
oh oh okay you said your thought yeah I
saw something in the water it's probably
a shark leo
what do you mean there are no sharks in
this water it's probably a shard at
Sweetwater you're a clever guy Leo you
don't problem now yeah look what you did
we have to do at the same time not yeah
one two three no good though it just
makes it a go faster okay oh you want to
pick up some speed I thought we better
go over
did you notice we both moved at the
exact same time get it look at it get a
fork a water
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
and this is good enough for me and wrote
this this this doesn't this is good
enough I don't need to do this in real
life ever again
waterfall waterfall
we're not done yet
in the front this is good it was a good
game man a good game this is all this is
for all those all those times that you
call me a big nose
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
like what singleplayer what if you huh
yeah
all that [ __ ] talking and I just saved
you look going after me won't be easy I
know but I'm going after with or without
you you want to end up dead I want him
gone he's a cold-blooded killer
the world's gonna be a better place
without him no he took the wrong side
that's the feel that never got to x-bar
you serious the diamond how the hell did
you pull that off a lot of planning and
a bit of luck so what happened
everything was going our way
we even had a buyer but that greedy [ __ ]
had other plans well yeah we don't curse
but this game curse
saw their count it
looks about right
of course it is you can always trust me
I'm not trusting nobody my friend
Hado
what do you think
Semmy that I thought it is
[Music]
pleasure doing business with you guys
you're too
this is nothing personal it's just
business give me the briefcase let's
take that gun
I'm antagonizing people on Twitter thing
I know I'm surrounded by cops that's
rough you guys miss points listen he's
the one who's gonna be sorry I'm making
things right for me and for my family
hmm sir do you know where Harvey is
right now I know one of his guys way
you'll know for sure so what are we
waiting for
let's go after him
you really want to take Harvey down huh
let's get him like I said with or
without you
I'm going after ya
listen without you addict there's a nose
in or out my nose was good but I now
find this rake I mean that's possible
that's definitely I want to see the face
scope actor who did this
Pete of an ultra [ __ ]
no sure [ __ ] oh they got the same
serial oh well I guess that's how you
stack in a supermarket la little boy
[Laughter]
I'm mad my daddy's coming home I wanted
to be a fatherless child Alex food yeah
she told her son that he was in college
[Laughter]
ask you some your daddy's in college
yeah sure that's gonna be it for your
birthday how do you manage to stay
together in this life
oh that's loud I've always been together
I can hear the game in the mic twelve
Margo women
Oh
hello all right there we go
to solve this
how to fix it you guys sounds great
all right okay so Jeff uh ten seven
extra sampling the new SSD solution I
can't remember if I repeat cover this
price would be terrible sama console
life looks rough out of here Microsoft
got their own proprietary they're gonna
do we do the console figure out the
storage solution
huh what did he do that bastard's been
cheating on me and nobody cheats on
Martha I guess he didn't know that good
luck anyway that's the cheating husband
yep haha King is a voyeur what's come on
all in there King one in the King got
next homie open that door oh they're
just shaking the okay oh that gotta be
that lady's husband maybe I should tell
him
did he start you'll start it quick
that's your man with the boxer shorts on
doing the business man
hey lady did you find him come with me I
might know this is it on pc though you
see that trailer over there I appreciate
it let's get it come on come on come on
Suze oh we got an achievement no
cheating
why we snips started my bad homeboy I do
apologize but no man should get dressed
that quick you gotta pay we gotta we
gotta see this through we gotta see this
no no she beat them up I think they're
gonna leave
oh she killed the dude let's go we don't
want to be witnesses I'm gonna talk to
the baseball dude you go oh yeah we can
play baseball for now get off the back
my guy can I have a go sure thing
yeah
oh my the way hey what's up I'll do a
few pictures all right go ahead take its
way thank you
yep go ahead hold it with me okay
you know all my favorite picture was
[Laughter]
Mariano you know I still won right one
night but I did wasn't counting my joint
like that you talk to that guy I'm
putting some wood pores kind of busy
yeah I can see that but I'm wondering if
you've seen a 30-something woman with a
kid this tall yep she's hot right of
course she is my wife
yeah okay so when was the last time you
saw her I see her every day oh yeah
where's she at how come you don't know
would your lovely wife this don't be a
smartass man just tell me where she is
Oh continue down that road all right oh
you are allergic to kitsch
there's only one way to look at your
cook
relax wow you got to talk to them
because you got low morals so we went to
this car
beats me just do my job
looks pretty banged up you sure you can
fix it damn sure I can Oh like a skill
the can all right let me go I'm gonna
get your baby back damn you don't like
me I don't want you to see your kid go
teach this kid a lesson
grab old people we can grab kids now
holies puri rod had died cops
hey guys that's the type of woman you
need one that won't think just check on
do that anymore night I smoke when
stinking behind and somewhere in the
bushes that's a kid you did all that to
break out of jail you'll keep doing any
of BTO yeah yeah nice to my man goatee
doctor strange at first you need to go
talk to Alex of course talk to your son
tell them how you escaped Jill how he
said could be commending you cuz nobody
could ever get out of that jail so if we
did it so easily
my wife yeah yo what's up MA
your writer Darcy hey Alex oh hell no
this good boy on just one other window
like father like son man he's already
learning how to break out of prison fast
I'm sorry and what type of dude is this
he sit there just watch them run off
into traffic
oh you found another minigame we gotta
play all right that's lighter I'm coming
now could you go get my kid every scoop
let's play some darts
[Laughter]
hey you gotta cheat all the secret rap
from regular nine five one King Bri mom
to show that kid what's up you do none
of my like she my ride and I dunno what
you I need a ride a bag of money worth
it those kid some kid back this poor
daddy where I got this hammer about to
beat this kid back into submission
keep it kid unless unless to kick the
ball I'm gonna go back to the chilla to
see what these deals is doing did he
ever get a chance
I'm surprised that I didn't just cut my
son with that big-ass nose you didn't
but he's like it's like you're just
gonna fall off because my nose cut look
at their four okay come on Benson okay
guys one game I love how we escaped
prison and we're over here playing
basket oh shoot playing baseball
Oh pass that ball now nothing yeah my
skills is crazy
hey little dude hit the ball back aah
what is he doing
Bassam if you gotta give it back that's
had the street ball rules us my skills
is incredible as Angeline shortie
doo-wop your good Alex
your kid's gonna get back home would you
look at that
toughing a boy we are but I need to get
going soon yeah I know I'm just happy to
see him soon trust those strange men
around your boy eat you
Oh myself look away there - so this is
home now not for long look you ain't got
nothing on me you know let's get out of
here and you really think Harvey will
leave us alone
bastard how the [ __ ] could I tell it
Harvey
it is what it is I broke the kid ink
will come anything's way out of here
come in Diablo dude come on midnight
actually we got no cheats I need to find
out
have you seen him lately yeah he's
working at that new construction site
down needed more polygons in the pants
you got talk to the way out dings I'll
take care of it you just make sure to
get back safe okay yeah no don't just
gammy get back safe or I'll kick your
ass okay
Oh whew the balls by the way do you
still have that piece I do
ah buddy
another girl with a gun dangerous
what's she good don't see what's here
ocking four or five what's that
oh yeah it to the side cuz you can't
kiss the street up used to be was
supplying okay
that's right stop sneaking out the
window
apparently there is he got shot right
there apparently there is gonna be a
third party stuff in July while we're
just going by what they say the first
place
big third party stuff big heavy na will
give us Harvey's location yeah they're
heavy hitter but one thing got partners
have you get it can I knock before D
heavy hitters this way
we're here to talk to someone
what's the problem what do you think
this is a coffee shop this is a
construction site you can't just waltz
in here
come on forget this dude come on we
don't have time for this whoa hey
I'm calling the cops you're gonna do
what hey relax Thor I got this what's
your name what do you need my name for
what's your name
all right it's Larry all right Larry
this is how it's gonna be me and my
friend here we're gonna walk in there do
you think you viral trolls will be at
the July event problem
what King said are you serious do I look
like I'm joking
do I know sup no thanks
where can I find him it's easy just ask
around all right Larry thank you yeah
you're welcome
Larry's three buns son all you got to do
is apply a little pressure he folder
like my boy did but you know being nice
gonna work - I'm sure it does but I
can't help it
I've been like this since I was a kid
you were probably just a sweet little
boy no I wasn't I don't know what you're
talking about
relax that tough guy are you being
sarcastic me yeah I'm just keeping you
honest come in no look so much but this
piece of [ __ ] don't work
you should do what I do when things
don't work what's up manga here you go
no hello anybody over still not working
how about you take a break and help me
find it for me okay
well can you at least tell me about his
whereabouts
straight away keep going that way I'm
gonna go see Austin you over there I
talked to that guy right there let's do
this three two one nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you think I broke my my X button I
don't know man you know how I am leave
me alone
sure you don't want to miss you
beautifully bright I'm not of your
business
could you please reach him fine hello
hello hello over here oh dang it is not
working
alright I'm coming man I was just
roughing up this dude down here Oh
talk to the blanket I didn't talk to the
black guys they're wrong looks like you
just spit it out
it's too here I told you it should be
four oh no what are you some kind of
stupid I think you misunderstood
that's the guy go home but Sir
oh [ __ ]
after I do this fast look at you looky
oh I got him I'm right on him being
getting away from me Oh God
don't you love how this dude hasn't
stand out run both of us like this what
he he crazy fat look like you eat pretty
clean all day I'm gonna kiss you keep
doing it Oh God
did agree this doing this ever made at
the wharf awaiting them do
[Music]
oh I'm running after
Wow hey relax
look let's focus on finding him first
whatever let's go
he said yeah let's compound our state
with Class D felonies mix them with a
little bit of a1 felonies
are you supposed to be with me
you know
this due to some place well you know
they never come on it you know the next
game we need to play king or madam a DM
or whatever it's both oh yeah Oh madam
is it a game pad then I'm buying no
games make them play the trees out here
fruit nope I got him open the door come
on what are you doing look at the hall
each sickly oh you got that piece of
[ __ ] I'm gonna kill you hey [ __ ] let's
use that cradle there okay
yeah I'm gonna use the crane and you
gonna get on the hook Wow thank you
hey come on out let's go swing me over
man gman flew all the way up come on
thank you appreciate it what's that he
says he's fighting game Pass
[Music]
yeah oh come on man I'm come on
yo your boy the crazy G oh come on fight
them I'm fighting them fight them beat
them up I don't know
[Laughter]
oh you would have died it was ugly
little my guy man let's just be extra
[Music]
I'll go round them over break his jaw
let's tip his wings so he can't fly look
at that no pop in you see that guy's
that's a whole city power - I'm telling
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me huh
make him cry I want to the point I love
what you could do with this you could
stick it up your ass
wait for now and you're better than you
but I see things that could make this
guy talk what do you say guys come on
I've got a few ideas
yeah me too I like pushing off the roof
no let me get the lips
[Music]
oh this is gonna hurt smartass huh you
want to use his arm again somewhere in
Mexico I don't know where exactly but
he's in Mexico it's got a big mansion
there it's true I swear
so that's where the red is hiding huh
yeah that's where yes don't tell him I
told you
you don't tell me what to do all right
all right calm down see you later let's
go guys let's go kingpin Netflix their
dough we're gonna be in the next season
yeah we're gonna need bigger guns than
this that's probably a good ain't goin
cash what are you doing what's going on
man a little like weight hog throw step
aside I got this man
relax youngster Jim eat a lot like okay
yeah me too brutal there you go near a
Bluto
entra yeah let's go vamanos group oh I
got a contact that might fly us down to
Mexico
these dudes is moving around a lot for
some I got a big guns can't risk robbing
a bank now their way least of all the
bank's what's that like what
what does this do printing
well people got subscriptions to porn up
that's nasty
a gas station you think they'll have
enough money they better have I'm not
going after Harvey with just a hang on
yeah
well yes there's only one way to find
out okay then
you ready yeah why don't you oh we need
to keep a low profile that's not really
your thing I say we do this the best way
man just in and up I say we do this the
easy way let's not make a scene what you
wanna do is let us keep it wild man
we've been wild all day sure whatever
man
while we keep in a while I thought I
picked the one that you picked no I
picked that other one because you went
over there I wanted to run in there guns
blazing oh not Roy Rogers is Roy and
Rogers then Roy Rogers go out of
business
excuse me what do you want Sam I woke up
on the wrong side this morning this
country is on the wrong side just look
at these gas prices
yeah prices are high tell me something I
don't know maybe I can I was in another
station about a mile back that way it
had much cheaper gas through this check
it out
you serious yeah going over there
they're much cheaper huh all right
thanks buddy I'll check it out have a
good one
Cooper crap was that hey you okay sure
why are you asking cuz you looked a
little freaked out I'm fine you sure
yeah just leave me alone arm and a leg
in here oh we got to get people out of
the store
you know I think there's a grocery store
down the street a lot cheaper oh really
there is yeah it's about a 10-minute
walk from here you just followed the
road down that way oh that's great
thanks for the tip
I got my guys out of still got the gas
guy going to what you okay you can't get
this guy out I think you have to get him
out
whoa hey don't sneak up on me like that
sorry no just looking around I don't
know
you kind of look nice I do
thanks I guess you can't have it all
right let me talk to this dude I can't
get him out of here for the trip can I
help you with something
hey ma'am hmm I don't want to use not
done so please so put a register for me
you're wasting your time there's barely
any money in there let me be the judge
of that
open it please
here look
there's a safe in the back isn't there
no there isn't
right hands up ma'am
everybody stay calm we don't want to
hurt anybody
Liam there's the safe in the back we
should check it out
don't trust this dude move keep that guy
control don't leave him
well you said for me to go to the safe
oh damn you try to shoot him yeah sure I
was a both you he wasn't supposed to go
in there I was supposed to shoot that
dude I was gonna give him those hot ones
all right so look
stay with the guy over get punched in
the mouth oh you got the revenge bet on
it good sleep let's take about the work
[ __ ] gun
it's combination combination food
[Music]
I don't want to hurt you but I will just
give me the combination
that one to me so let's get it let's get
it let's get out of here Oh people they
pull up just let oh please let all Rome
or Plata Rome or Plata
[Music]
damnit she's walking toward you
that's crazy big clothes what years a
certain 70 what ya think I'm 70
sometimes just make sure to be always
right five yeah I know
alright see you there so we got the guns
you trust this person I do
stop worrying Vincent it's not go for
your heart my heart is just fine
why are you trying to muffle me what
we're dealing with relax mr. paranoid I
trust her okay besides she owes me one
now let's go get those guns if you say
so you need to relax more all right yeah
yeah
here we go
Jasmine Leong you're good I'm good
who's this guy don't worry he's with me
mmm oh yeah
I'm Vincent oh hello Vincent how nice to
meet you you're a [ __ ] idiot
what why don't you bring your whole
family next time I'm out hey what's
wrong with you what's wrong with me what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you you think I'm
vending ice cream here listen I told you
I don't do business with strangers and
this guy he looks like a stranger to me
do you have a problem with me yeah I got
a problem with you you have a problem
with me
now you want to do relax
what to calm down Jasmine put the gun
down
come on I told you he's with me look I
see no matter what you pick I'm gonna be
like hey remember that's right there
look but it's the last time and then
we're even
here this should be more than enough
hurry up [ __ ] first please I know
what you're gonna pick you that do baby
aren't you this down my way let me take
that some juice oh I'm trying to figure
out cuz I'm trying to walk how you
scream see nice the brand-new mp5
perfect for close quarters combat very
good place for target practice around
here try shooting at those empty houses
that should do the trick
good idea let's see what kind of damage
this bad boy can do
I'm appointing authority place oh my
what's the this over Oh Bobby
wait you try to get this one I'm gonna
throw a bottle you were well enough
healing to dip out I can't party bro you
ready I'm sorry no any time she's dead
now with you huh oh we can do the walk
out of the wall I don't get the washdown
killers do it I'll be dead
go all right
I'm cool with this gun I want to make
sure I have the right weapon I got the
right weapon lead it and women of
another the ain't gotta tuck and roll
with your weapon
bye Felicia
oh man see our platforms and all that
that was back when he couldn't do black
people make up in the days
five leaks
uh-oh your drink adrene Weber oh she's
snitching I told you I didn't trust her
never trust a woman with hoop earrings
[Laughter]
hey it's me
I got some information about Leo okay
you know where he is
give me its location don't worry about
that just tell me where he is
got it good job talk to you later
are they gonna do with the big shoulders
Harvey Harvey what's up
I found it good make sure we put a best
guy on this I want him dead you got it
yes boss
that's a nice house all the living
lavishly nobody statues like a fit in
the house got off the lavish living
Harvey
the one to the hospital
that was the old wallpaper you have back
in your house or they were sort of water
break
hey can you stop by that phone booth
over there are you sure you can get us a
plane I sure hope so yeah me too man no
mark DeCarlo optimist
I'm playing the game right now
well there's your phone yep
I'll look around make sure to get us
that plane let me get on the phone let
me call my wife but I already know she
went into labor it's not my baby I
thought she's happy I'm in jail what I
got the other sizes where maybe no she
won't change
she wouldn't the internet label with a
few dude that you with the school way
varsity anything I can do for you can do
that since the dude you're talking to
the dude that was talking some glue in
high school give me some cigarettes
filtered in this stuff you need a lot of
bag Ali treat so married man that's my
luck how did you know
yo I gotta stop me chicks in the back
man that you get you sure I think she's
fine
it sure is this is not what it looks
like
I'll save you no okay that's right just
hanging around so uh have a good night
oh love how to use their crowbar using
it all wrong blending in with the
darkness I got to get away from you look
two ways who's your friend Victoria Oh
your man is in the window who's that
be careful buckaroo banzai was annoying
though
number those phone booths that wasn't
easy way to catch the coronavirus hey
Vincent
yeah I'm fine thanks look I need to fly
somewhere tomorrow we're thinking : is
where I think that work okay great
what
when nowhere no wife went into labor
broke where she the babies bleh it was
that it was that black dude at the
construction side of wouldn't let you
talked but I need to go what what are
you talking about you okay I'm fine but
I need to be at least that I'm here with
my boss and knees ready just walk away
I'm not walking away and I need to be
there all right Vincent come too far to
back down now you need to talk to me
tell me what's going on in your head
talk to me
Oh Oh God okay fine
it's my wife you tell people that you
playing again she's screaming and they
think that's always a great time in
Turkey got those [ __ ] yeah I'm out of
here son your man got a silencer he
bought his business real
god bless they left beat them all you
got a silencer you ain't man plane
you got to push this from front of it
know what I'm out of here I'm talking
push that in front of that door
this should buy some time we gotta get
it here
I know okay
[ __ ] good thing I already did this
please
this guy's mentally deranged man no not
my god I always gotta act here here here
here yeah we could've both took this
Deus healing to like Jack Nicholson from
the shyness thumbs up
we put my controller under that strain
again he thought he had something with
that silencer he thought it was sweet we
started pop is going to keep sending
guys like oh there it goes again
oh there it goes again I know what do
you know
no no what's the problem we just had a
baby that's great news
congrats man sure it's it's great thanks
you don't seem too happy about it
trust me I'm happy it's just
strawberries what's up my door fishes
look complicated or not you gotta go see
your kid
whatever is going on with me you two
still your kid I know you're right of
course I am you know I
yeah my gosh that plane didn't we are
doing it again yeah well I can like hear
myself like a huge feedback off of you
hello yeah it's still like that just try
unplugging yourself and plug it back in
hello yeah there we go that's way better
yeah Kenny I I didn't mean it in a bad
way you know but yeah anyway it's a
great thing watching you kid grow up
yeah I can imagine it is what's wrong
man what's the problem with you in your
life
well yeah I'm in prison so Carol I love
my life you've always wanted to have a
child tried for you it was wrong retile
we failed it was like a part of his died
and when it finally happened that day
when we found out you've never been so
happy then everything went to hell
and I ended up in prison
mamita
this colvett stuff has made a lot of
bills easy to pay online
I don't even charge freeze money we're
in the hospital now it's not a baby
their section should know where to go
good evening ma'am I don't know they
seem pretty straightforward to me put
the Gator and then follow the signs
thank you got a face on it my guy you're
gonna go over yeah she said gone
elevator take her to the top floor
kwang-ho huh come on Vincent let's go
hello this
well always my joint connect for catch
all this smoke
oh man I made a mistake yeah you won I
make a mistake I try to put in the
middle ah suck it loser
[Music]
come on there you go there you go come
on
you forced my hand so it's one to one to
one to one
so act like you box him in the corner
get his nose - sniffling come on come on
Mariano's ready there you go that's the
guy no oh yeah come on now let you in
just so we hurry up with the game oh
you're man with the mustache Anna
formally mother's strip it really does
look too portals like okay okay
but your faces are so familiar sure I've
seen
come on FTW hey I'm about all this
Bassel you need help man what just don't
like taking risks that's all
and I complete without often stuff is
not a risk at all excited see you baby
more nervous understandable
I was nervous too but don't worry you'll
be fine thank you can we still a baby
Emily oh what's happening here you're
about to be taken they got so many games
that I beat you at almost all to you
are you gonna watch me
Wow
my hair brother live on that bus you
know what those things will kill you
yeah they pretty much already have
long have the doctors given you four
months maybe less who knows that's tough
I'm so sorry don't be thanks you feel
quite relaxed about it you do yeah you'd
be amazed how much acceptance relaxes
the mind
you got it
I'm trying it one more time and that's
all
[Music]
as buggy we stop do you have to cheat I
know I can get relations what do you boy
girl girl boy well I hope you don't mind
me asking but I don't see the father
around good for nothing
maybe that's for the best him not being
around yeah that's what I keep telling
myself don't go begging for daddy get
away from that PlayStation Coco I might
give you something baby what's the name
please
Oh Carol already right just follow me
sir thank you this dude is our head just
wasn't the cops be posted up at her a
joint Coco hey Leo you coming come on
leo
who's not like me please leo we don't
have all day oh there it goes
that was weird he came in nose first
I'm fine
Vincent what are you doing here you know
I'm with Tyrone now she's my daughter
too
this is Leo we broke out for yoga room
yeah baby girl huh I'll leave you guys
alone I'll be waiting outside some
respectful fugitives
you see that's my way watch out for the
ponies can I hold her you're my baby I'm
out the window
yawn see you're still in drugs and you
taking them she is
the touching moment I mean daddy
probably yeah yeah no no it started no
no it started me to say I just want you
to trust me okay
things will be different you keep saying
that but you're gonna get yourself
killed I can't live with that
I'm not gonna let that happen violet
promise
yeah can you you have to trust only
Harrell you know what I gotta do I gotta
buy a better headset wire y'all do not
buy the wires from Amazon son is it that
I brought a replaceable you just told me
it's a replacement wire obviously yeah
Holies downstairs I told you to snitch
this out Mike
[ __ ] they said we need to get that out
there you look shooting we're in the
hospital okay let's go
fight bye
I'm up to fire speech this is the
dumbest thing ever
remember kids when you're on the run
don't go to public places for someone
afford a rent afford to get out of you
no it was a girl we could have tackled
oh you're gonna pack with a black guy
[Laughter]
when you try to save you
Oh get that security go they all got a
good security guard stop thinking a cop
over there the black guy that will Marie
Bobo you got it sneak use the sneaking
button
[Laughter]
it's amazing how we were able to get out
away we're fugitives that's what we do
oh yeah this is the best fight scene
it's 2d fighting it's severe to do the
mustache do what now I put the security
guards see them up this game tackled a
lot of different things the
cinematography is really good it worked
really well on this day this 2d beat
them up is nice I like it
oh man I gotta fight holy
I'm surprised you ain't streaming on
Twitch glorious twitch they only gonna
show it in 720p
they throttling him
[ __ ]
though this is a very well-put-together
game is nice awesome
no he's black man shooting the black
[Music]
bleeding Jerome how you get captured
you go take his black card away we all
become hostages we hostage
good evening ma'am
we have two fugitives at-large in the
hospital right now I know I know my
colleague just called me I think these
two guys in the paper yes
everybody with the router you stay safe
stay away call for any Oh blossom cake
them you know if there's anything else I
can do that Karen I like quickie we've
got all that you rich and with a big-ass
mouth
I'm walking out the front door now that
seemed like it hurt a little bit
bringing our charges up to a grand total
I mean we are already going back to jail
I'm helping by running away
Starsky and Hutch baby series boy they
got you off the Build America
it is Starsky and Hutch busy I got a
body like Fe the creatine yeah don't
they don't you love how they do in this
part of slow motion oh yeah oh my god I
can't believe he's here to save his
Manson if he was free to go
we just wanted to pig nose the great
kazoo what does this do doing he's
dancing oh really
come on at it you guys do better than
that
huh I didn't even see nothing pop up
start running they're pressing that X
but he dancing he dancing again I don't
think he's supposed to be here
we'll have new shot let's get it daddy
[Music]
what the hell that's an unusual load
time
[Music]
sure it's a good pilot right yeah kind
of sure come on man you know I'm not a
fan of heights don't worry
Emily's a great pilot she was
practically born on the play so they was
able to get out of the city huh long
time no see Vincent how you doing good
hey leo nice to meet you
future oh man you look like a bee love
so you're a friend I guess yeah I hear
you good pilot
well I don't know about that but thanks
okay Emily does this thing fly what does
it look like a [ __ ] bike of course it
flies where we going Mexico Mexico
you've got to be kidding me that's way
too far I'm not flying to Mexico Emily
you know I always pay you good if you
want to go to Mexico you're gonna have
to pay me between more than good what
pay you double
just take us there double huh you could
for that Vince yeah yeah
where are you going where do you think
Mexico
the truth I would never say anything I
would never do that you know that I
didn't say anything that they tried to
get me to say something but I didn't
because that's not what I do you know
that you know you gotta trust me Harvey
I promise please please guys a liar you
let him go Harvey could smell a liar
good hard what are you thinking
we need more men he's coming got it oh
yeah one Nima Kevin this is Thomas my
swamis yeah hey here you go
we're gonna take you this oh is this
Emily really don't even ask
musashi that's what got kicked out the
house you ready sure the gas tax right
from there yeah
what do you think is this a good landing
spot let me see
yeah but it's gonna be a long walk
through a dense jungle that's fine
you could also parachute down here that
would get you way closer
no thanks I'm not good with Heights
whatever you want
wait rubbers do you have parachutes here
I do
hell no Vincent you crazy do you know
how much time that would save us I don't
care I haven't even seen a parachute
before it's not that hard
you just pull a cord right Emily well
technically you're right come on what do
you say
I'm definitely bad [ __ ] alright alright
I mean how hard can it be right
don't worry you'll figure it out when I
wait down hey before we jump
yeah you better are you being cocky now
what No
whatever just show me the basics I got
this good Emily
I'll handle the fuel all right
sorry that's just it's it's coming with
just get it on the plane okay got it are
you sitting there worrying about huh and
this girl was the one who ratted us out
I got to play with wood every chance I
get pause please filled up the fuel line
more we got please we're Navy brothers
look what I found what do you got here
I don't know game or something oh yeah
let's play oh man watch me oh okay I
think you got to do nice
oh you have to jump okay oh what's that
a vow oh those boomin you completely
panicked there and it still gave it to
you
[Music]
let's bowl
this is ridiculous
[Music]
[Laughter]
we got open the doors all right
open this door I'm ready to go let's
open up the gates
Leo let's go
oh go like this game
Oh pull up
I do a video today
you nervous
No
you
a little bit
just enough to keep me focused you know
that's good yeah
you know
I've been thinking about your situation
with your wife
I might have a solution for you okay
find me guy write her a letter
what look I don't mean to interfere but
out a similar situation with Linda so I
decided to write her a letter and it
worked I laid it all out and she gave me
a second chance you know I'm saying that
writing a letter really helped you know
I mean of course it's up to you I mean
I'm just saying that worked for me but
it doesn't have to you know anyways look
I'm just saying it was a good thing
that's all you feel me yeah well I don't
really the writing type yeah yeah I mean
it was just an idea
it's just anyway congrats on the baby
I'm really happy for you thank you
you know what's the disconnect with this
these people don't know each other from
Adam
they only with each other because they
broke out of jail kind of sucks if you
don't build a connection with the
characters here we go why'd you do that
go complain just balls
Oh God
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what is your worst experience ever that
you know that would be a horrifying
experience for individual
[Laughter]
because I'll try to figure out how come
your dream I joined didn't say let's get
going we're gonna you think Harvey
Stillwater diamond I do what makes you
so sure about that
I don't know God feeling I guess and
it's not like it's easy to sell
something like the black are long I
still don't get how the hell you pull
that off well I'm actually good at what
I do
did you press any please stop eating
attic definite Evy thank you I thought I
thought I was the one that was gonna
press stay low let's flank them
flank them go in the other side
I know we're gonna
I got the joint they come with the
Tucker Road huh no huh huh the ruffles
is mine then little puffs is yours
no actually did you look in there go see
what shows don't mind but looking at a
Cilla's you're sure that you eat one
then keep looking or if you got a 50 Cal
human being
rat-a-tat-tat blow out your back huh I
came with a duck and roll button buddy
knows I gotta cut the robot you know
breath a in roll
no man look in there fine yo [ __ ] yes
you do yes you do
keep going looking a cat in it huh
whoa
oh do you see how they flying after
poeple
boy
I don't gotta still W I don't have a gun
to do business all right
this doesn't make anything
let me go down this up your help
oh I gotta kill you the sniper from the
sniper you did all the work I wanted to
get down there help you they didn't want
me down in the trenches come on leo help
me lift this door press X
ha they think a cut-down bridge is going
to stop us what a joke
come on leo help me lift this door what
if you huh
too bad I'm not on vacation wow I didn't
know Mexico was this beautiful stop
staring at me I need yo addict doesn't
this look familiar it literally looks so
familiar
Oh
is your back done
let me
you see I'm as dumb as a boat oh okay I
got you
Boosh that's me if you can I'm the
gingerbread man
take the doodle top
I've not either closed worries
you know what I like you don't got to
give bullets hey Leo help me with this
alright that actually worked
brute force always a winner change my
weapon are you nuts
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no I did not
[Music]
[Music]
my cookie crisps other don't talk about
I like barbecue man how amazing
yeah
oh I think it is dude at the top
I can't see
whatever si
I'm done
oh you got it already right cool easy
ese ready come on let's go well it'll go
close oh man this dude's house is
amazing
Tony Montana in the face you get a whole
bunch of coke shikaku you got a grenade
launcher you just gave it out Dustin
orderly
I've been natively
pick here the guys at that moon
that the longest is weapon
I got a cheese me I'm putting it down
come in half luck rib shot with the
black diamond give me the blood diamond
no no I must sit at my favorite chair
before I go out of here
don't even think about it
give me the diamond as the man with the
Golden Gun
tell me of my brothers stuff point we
are supposed to eat that my guy shut the
[ __ ] up
one more word from you now put a bullet
in your face wait wait wait leo
I still got it that's what you're here
for right the diamond it's all yours
didn't I say over there you can take it
come on get up
go you gonna let him open the safe
you'll become an agent my guys she's
winning me cat clip his wings clip his
wings you got a grenade in there hey
[Music]
[Music]
there you go all in the mouth go that's
the best way that you can kill a boss
[Laughter]
unsatisfactory
I got satisfaction I'm good I'm good
with this this is a good game that's the
best way to kill a boss you got the
diamond money or motorcycle come let's
get out of here
[Music]
vamanos the kill heavy what really happy
more taken heavy
[Applause]
[Music]
I can tell you this this is Ben
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they're jumping Wow
oh yeah I was getting away with so much
flavor and stuff I thought I was
invincible my bet
so literally for the left
[Laughter]
whoa for one you see you're both got to
do good to get out of here I like this
look
why do I gotta be the one behind this
you're later buddy dammit hold up
someone's called is the developer is
just up Nick let's look back
why do you keep dying in the same spot
though
Oh take cash
[Music]
it's a dick
not dying in Mexico
I've been lucky you come on man we gotta
make it out of Mexico addict
awful boredom addict
all right let me catch up the Attic some
reason a daggers ahead of me hit the dip
one they got a helicopter
[Music]
[Laughter]
is it noses holding you back let's go
what's funny is those played with what
hair I wasn't even some how was it
dyeing wow you have we not dying with
her names like why am I the only one
getting shot Oh
[Applause]
whether to the college anything going
hey man you guys are crazy visit you're
gonna have to pay me triple for this you
got it you got a girl we got that
diamond that's it you're not gonna hear
me say this often but thanks you too leo
you know what I think I'm gonna write
that letter to Carol that's a great idea
hey Emily you have a pen and paper
wait now why not it's a long way home
you got anything better to do
not really all right
how are we doing we should be landing in
ten minutes okay
what's Lou up to sleeping about time to
wake him up then yeah
are you okay Vincent yeah you sure yeah
I'm fine
leo what yeah we did it yeah
look at all the points hey Polly
quarters after you kill the business to
set us up you know got high hands up
cheering for me I'm looking at
everything you gonna trust this girl Oh
juicy a cop
special agent flick back
it's your hair slicked back shut that
door everybody stand down
Oh moustachio we but we bout to go back
to jail we're gonna break out of jail
again
he gonna do
we got the diamond I know you had that
there you go good job Vincent blows I'm
a cop I'm sorry leo
into deeply oh you big nose
[Laughter]
that was leaked
we had you know why--i long time ago you
know watching you fish yes please yes
damn that into big Donnie Brasco them
right
yeah of course it is you can always
trust me
I'm not trusting nobody my friend
trustful guy Adel what do you think huh
semi that I thought
it is
pleasure doing business with you guys
all right he's got it finally
[Music]
somebody get a damn ambulance
Gary stay with me please
pennies dollar he's not with you anymore
[Music]
you're in big trouble you understand
[Music]
where's Harvey
where's the black warlock what are you
deaf
well you think you're funny don't you
we think you just go and sell it on a
street corner
what are you stupid you that stupid
it's all gonna rain down on you hard
you got it he's not gonna say a word
gonna [ __ ] it all animal
there's suddenly one option now I gotta
go with you that one on it I'm gonna get
that nose game if you want Harvey in the
black war love this is the only way just
put me in a cell next door you're too
close to this Vincent you better sit
this one out
gary was my brother my flesh and blood
and he's dead because of me
I put him in that situation I need to do
this and you know it just make it happen
James
you're under arrest Leo it's over nobody
move I'll [ __ ] kill that will be
making a worse for yourself
man why you gotta be like this king
[Music]
stay away don't make me shoot him move
and I'll shoot how you feel about thank
you put some ketchup on it that's a
mouthful I wasn't going down like that
Keane please just calm down shut up shut
the [ __ ] up
Oh go you know what's funny
when we're playing the exact keep
talking keep talking Winston keep
talking King I kill you
I'll kill you with the quickness
I'm out of it you gonna do
I'm out of here man
[ __ ] what you are you gotta get out of
here kid
[Music]
thank you I'm not breaking this is not
where I in
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wisel it should be slow motion like this
is bull
[Music]
you think yeah in a water little 4 foot
Emily I'm dead I'm dead you could go
home send me down over here he afraid I
can't do push-ups hit him in his calf
muscle you'll be get a stick arrest this
kid roosters kid ain't no use my kid
history where we got the chick I ho
wearing a wire
I just son wearing a wire - a little
tighten shorts - he had on I'll go this
way
you gonna choke out doesn't you gonna do
you're gonna run down on it go don't do
anything stupid Leo shut up just go I
don't want to hurt you Emily just get
out you know I can't do that
don't [ __ ] push it this is between me
and Vincent now get the hell out get out
go you got duct tape on his vest my guy
imma shoot you in that duct-tape spot
you found my weakness I know you're
disappointed but Harvey killed my
brother
I had no choice I can't [ __ ] believe
this
I'll talk to the captain will reduce
your sentence by sex you're a dead man
you brings a shake
what about your son Alex shut the [ __ ]
up don't you mention his name you don't
get to message
here now you piece of [ __ ] you're dead
man you piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
oh it's on you took murder with impunity
oh my gotta find him can't let him get
away
I wonder what that pig is hiding
[Music]
get away you done talking oh my god
Oh
come on I see you bitching you can't
hide for me Matt issues just black our
screens and oh you can see your screen
and I could see my screen
Oh
[ __ ] you do it
now you see see this step push it away
Leo don't do this
on your knees I said on your knees
[Music]
[Music]
I was further up started patting close
good shot - oh I lost the gun who lost
it gun where my legs both knees looking
we just take it
[Laughter]
I can't hit you man I love after their
bang buddy buddies nobody
oh it look like a cop you got a cop
mustache dad to cover up that chin cuz
you to do over the top oh god this is
gonna hurt sure Oh
see that's the knee I'm taking this
holiday taking that very me you just
elbowed me you just need to hit me with
me that's the neon aching yeah I want
that I want that overnight it on UPS
please I had that we already seen how
much fanfare cyberpunk is getting over
men the sales basically stopped for
animal crossing see you're done son
I'm gonna let you get it Oh get there
big man sorry bad I'm sorry it just has
to be done so long yes all you let me
kill you you want that's right Wolverine
we're gonna hold you five kidding
consecutive life sentences I wrote that
note give this to my wife my guy
if my letter to Carol
I stay in the victor
[Music]
your pain has just begun we got away
from killing your son the jail eat is
drying up as we speak he's in the foster
care system now my son will be in there
too when they go straight after my son
[Music]
but I say
[Music]
[Music]
but no one day let us get out of jail
if this dude a locked up I'm telling you
right now this game is bogus it's bogus
because I killed you how things are man
you you make a bet against the attic man
you lose you lose your knee you lose
your life and I don't know no god that's
a policeman right there I bet the rest -
Wow
father baby look like a baby dog
who let this letter you know the letter
says right
he just left get him let us do with the
big nose killed me Carol get him he sees
me around you I'm sorry for the broken
promises and not being there when you
needed me I'm sorry for no longer being
the man you fell in love with my biggest
regrets are all the moments we did your
biggest regret should be messing with
attic man that's your biggest miss a
second together with you and our
beautiful daughter if you let man I'll
be the husband you was a Phil King and
the father I know I know that your best
wasn't enough worse for it and you'll
kneecap is Martin I'm eating my food I
gave my life
ei wants you to believe is okay to kill
cops that is not how it's supposed to
end I give this a bogus rating oh they
get him at the motel okay I'm cool
you're not happy
[Music]
hey Linda are you guys ready to leave we
are are you sure no one was following
you yeah fine let's just get gone
the van was right there I am fine
you have peace yeah peace with these
bars
yo she's the absolute worst cop ever
when I went inside she had him dead to
rights and she's just sitting it while
I'm dead I want my money back what is it
like how does it feel to know that you
lost this but you could have done
something
Wow knows the blade out you sold me out
many simple jesu how does it feel to
know that I got a wagon you did it how
does it feel to know that you died you
died on a rooftop with no way we're with
you and my nose my big nose look
yourself got away I accept the whole
police department what you do King shout
at the kids who for the $2 super chair
two years later the story is trash it's
it's so it's amazing kid it's a 98
because because King lost
you know what else man we need some
fraud alerts in there to the members
because he was a cop look we need some
bottlers there cuz King was an
undercover cop this whole time he was a
[Music]
king was a cop this whole time
I don't know how I feel about that I
throw away I feel a certain way maybe
was a cop this whole time I just did you
King we were friends and you betrayed me
you had a badge this whole time so King
book before I in the stream and what
what's your thoughts on a ways out I
thought it was one of the best
cooperative games story was like trash
we go with the end with the guy going
away after he kills a cop on the roof
that only you know all the police
station no we yet that's kind of stupid
but other than that I really like the
game I love the buddy cop system it was
fun our little fight at the end and then
I'm gonna put that separately on you you
know the one where you die at the end
and I win I'm the toy this is this this
is exactly what its gonna feel like when
I possess the knees at the end of this
year smelly I'm smelling this West
Virginia air and it's not
and of course the double agent so you
gonna find out handle crosses the
competent through the fight yo are you
guys that was our first community stream
we played the whole game we will talk to
you later at it can Keene were out peace